dear ur shaheen thank you very much for
hosting this vaccine equity for africa
event
dear president sal
diamaki
president akufo ado president kagame
and dear leaders from the who for
example dr tedras the african cdc
european investment bank and biotech
institutes
it has only been nine months
since we first proposed in paris the
idea to bring vaccine production to
africa
and today
that simple but ground-breaking idea is
seeing the light in the form of this
state-of-the-art biotech container
factory
like the one on display today
this year already
at least two of these containers
factories
will move to africa to ronda and to
senegal
where i just visited last week the
institute pasteur de dakar
close cooperation is ongoing with south
africa's biovac institute
and with our partners in ghana
we are advancing in record time
commercial production is set to begin in
2023
the vaccine equity for africa project
is only possible thanks to teamwork
starting with africa's declared ambition
to build its own vaccine production
capacity
teaming up with a european innovation
champion
such as biontech
supported by the european union and the
african union
governments in europe and africa
and the un system
this is how we emerge from the pandemic
and build a stronger future for africa
and europe
the initiative is first and foremost
about vaccine equity
vaccines from the new factories
will be sold at non-for-profit prices
exclusively to african countries
they will be made in africa for africa
with world-class technology
at the same time
this initiative can advance public
health and industry well beyond the
pandemic
we know the mrna technology is
revolutionary
it holds promises for the fight against
other diseases like malaria and
tuberculosis
biotech factories can be adjusted within
weeks to make different vaccines
it could thus be an african-made
solution
to diseases that currently kill millions
and this project is part of a large
ambition
by 2040
the african union wants that 60 percent
of the vaccines used on the continent
are manufactured on the continent
the european union fully supports that
goal
together with our member states and
financial institutions
we have committed over 1 billion euros
in financing
to strengthen regulatory frameworks
and transfer skills and know-how
because regional capacities are the
cornerstone of global public health
and the project goes even beyond public
health
building this technological capacity in
ghana rwanda senegal and south africa
countries that are regional leaders in
innovation
will strengthen the innovation ecosystem
on the entire continent
distinguished guests
there could be no better way
to prepare for the eu africa summit
tomorrow
this initiative shows the power of our
cooperation
it is a great example of our new global
gateway investment package
and it represents the immense potential
of our partnership as equals
it's a partnership
that benefits both
africa and europe
it creates new links between us
so welcome
to the future of eu africa cooperation
and many thanks for your attention